N
NEW YORK CITY AND THIS IS OPEN
FOR THE FIVE."
75 DAYS AFTER BEING PICKS TO
LEAVE THE RESPONSE OF THE BORDER
CRISIS VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS IS ON HER FIRST TRIP IN
GUATEMALA TODAY.
SHE SAYS STOPPING MIGRATION IS A
TOP PRIORITY BUT SHE'S ALREADY
AT ODDS WITH THAT COUNTRY'S
PRESIDENT OVER WHAT IS ACTUALLY
CAUSING THE PROBLEMS, THE VP
ALSO SAYING SHE WILL NOT BE
VISITING THE SOUTHERN BORDER
BECAUSE SHE IS FOCUSED ON
RESULTS INSTEAD OF GESTURES AND
AS THE ADMINISTRATION STRUGGLES
TO STOP AND INFLUX OF MIGRANTS.
>> I WANT TO BE CLEAR TO FOLKS
IN THIS REGION WHO ARE THINKING
ABOUT MAKING THAT DANGEROUS
TRACK TO THE
UNITED STATES-MEXICO BORDER, DO
NOT COME.
DO NOT COME.
AS ONE OF OUR PRIORITIES WE WILL
DISCOURAGE ILLEGAL MIGRATION.
AND I BELIEVE IF YOU COME TO OUR
BORDER, YOU WILL BE TURNED BACK.
>> Dana: GUATEMALA'S PRESIDENT
IS BLAMING PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
MESSAGING FOR THE RECORD SEARCH.
>> WE ARE GOING TO REUNITE
FAMILIES AND WE ARE GOING TO
REUNITE CHILDREN, THE VERY NEXT
DAY, ORGANIZING GROUPS OF
CHILDREN TO TAKE THEM TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THE LONGER GREAT, WHAT'D YOU
THINK ABOUT HER COMMENTS
ESPECIALLY TRYING TO WARN PEOPLE
OFF COMING TO THE UNITED STATES?
>> Greg: I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON GETTING YOUR
REAL ESTATE LICENSE.
THE JACKET LOOKS GREAT.
KAMALA'S MOTTO SHOULD BE "SHE'S
NOT VP, SHE IS "WHY ME?"
BECAUSE TECHNICALLY SHE IS NOW
OFFICIALLY A RACIST BECAUSE HOW
COULD HER SAYING WHAT SHE SAID
TO GUATEMALA.
DO NOT BE CONSTRUED ANY
DIFFERENTLY, SHE VIEWED IT
THROUGH THE FILTER OF RACE, THEY
WOULD BE RACIST.
IF YOU HAD A STRONG, FORCEFUL
POSITION ON THE BORDER WHICH
MOST REPUBLICANS DO, YOU ARE A
BAD PERSON, YOU WERE RACIST SO
NOW SHE GETS TO THE POWER AND
SHE SOUNDS LIKE A REPUBLICAN,
SHE SHOULD BE DENOUNCING HERSELF
FOR HER COLD, COLD STANCE
TOWARDS A PEOPLE DOWN SOUTH AND
IT SHOWS YOU HOW COME I THINK IT
ALSO SHOWS YOU HOW THE MEDIA
RESPONSE, NOW IF YOU CRITICIZE
KAMALA ABOUT HER JOB THESE DAYS,
SHE'S NOT UP TO THE JOB AND YOU
ARE AGAIN, RACIST OR SEXIST,
HOWEVER IT WAS A
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT THREW HER
OUT, DECEMBER 2019, SHE WAS THE
FIRST WANT TO GO, 3% AND WHO DO
THEY CHOOSE INSTEAD OF HER?
A REALLY OLD WHITE GUY WHO KNEW
SOMEBODY IN THE CLAN.
I THINK THE WORLD HAS SPOKEN,
KAMALA HARRIS IS A RACIST AND
THE MEDIA HAD EVISCERATED PEOPLE
AS BIGOTS FOR SAYING THE VERY
SAME THING AND IT MAKES ME THINK
MAYBE THE MEDIA IS PLAYING
FAVORITES, DANA.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE CASE,
I MAY NOT HAVE ENOUGH DATA ON
THAT BUT I THINK THEY MIGHT NOT
HAVE MEANT IT WHEN THEY WERE
CALLING EVERYBODY RACIST.
>> Dana: A LITTLE
DISINGENUOUS.
>> Greg: YES.
IF YOU SEE ANYTHING LIKE A FOUR
BEDROOM WITH A POOL IF YOU COULD
JUST, YOU KNOW, BOOKMARK THEM.
>> Dana: YOU NEED A BASEMENT
FOR ALL OF YOUR FERRETS AND THE
OTHER THINGS YOU DO IN THE
BASEMENT?
YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT, THIS DOES
LOOK LIKE A REAL ESTATE OUTFIT.
GERALDO RIVERA, YOU'VE BEEN IN
GUATEMALA IN THE PAST, DO YOU
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION PUT FORTH
TODAY THAT WOULD ACTUALLY GET TO
THE ROOT CAUSE?
>> Geraldo: I AM MUCH MORE
BULLISH ON MIGRATION THAN MOST
OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT IT IS THE
CHARACTERISTIC OF A ROBUST,
GROWING, VIBRANT COUNTRY THAT WE
TAKE THESE STRONG BACKS, WE
ABSORB THEM, LOOK AT ALL THE
HELP WANTED SIGNS, STAY THERE
YOU GET TWO BUCKS A DAY, COME
HERE YOU GET 20 BUCKS AN HOUR.
YOU KNOW, IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
GOING ON NOW, THE DYSFUNCTION OF
THE BORDER I THINK IS LAMENTABLE
AND I DO PUT THE RESPONSIBILITY
ON THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, I
THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS HARSH,
HE WAS A BULLY, HE TOOK THE
MEXICAN PRESIDENT, KIND OF
SLAPPED HIM AROUND, WE WILL PUT
TARIFFS ON YOU IF YOU DON'T
INTERVENE AND INTERCEDE AND STOP
THESE FOLKS FROM TAKING THE
2,000-MILE TREK ACROSS MEXICO TO
GET TO OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
BIDEN'S MESSAGE WAS MUCH MORE
BUSHY.
COME, COME, IT'S GREAT.
WHAT I SAID TO START MY LITTLE
SEGMENT HERE, IMMIGRATION IS
GOOD, THAT'S THE WRONG MESSAGE
FOR THE AMERICAN PRESIDENT, THE
AMERICAN PRESIDENT HAS TO SAY
STAY HOME, APPLY, GET ONLINE AND
SO FORTH AND AS A RESULT OF HIS
MIXED MESSAGING I THINK YOU HAVE
CHAOS NOW AND TRAGEDY BEING
ACTED OUT.
>> Dana: KAMALA HARRIS ALSO
RESPONDED TO G.O.P. CRITICISM,
TAKE A LISTEN.
SPEAK ON THE ISSUE OF
REPUBLICANS POLITICAL ATTACKS OR
CRITICISM OR EVEN CONCERNS, THE
REASON I AM HERE IN GUATEMALA AS
MY FIRST TRIP AS VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES IS BECAUSE
THIS IS ONE OF OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES, AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO BE FOCUSED ON THAT KIND OF
WORK.
>> Katie: OKAY, VISITING THE
BORDER WHERE THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF AMERICAN CITIZENS AFFECTED BY
THIS CRISIS IS SOME KIND OF
GRAND GESTURE, IT'S NICE AT THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS IN GUATEMALA
TO FIGURE OUT THE ROOT CAUSE OF
THIS, WHATEVER THEY WANT TO COME
UP WITH SO THEY CAN EXCUSE SOME
OF THEIR OWN POLICY POSITIONS.
YOU CAN TALK A LOT BUT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE POLICY POSITIONS TO
BACK IT UP NOTHING'S GOING TO
CHANGE.
AND SHE TALKS ABOUT REPUBLICAN
CRITICISM.
IT'S NOT JUST REPUBLICANS, IT'S
BORDER STATE DEMOCRATS, LIKE
HENRY CUELLAR, THE PHOTOS OF A
CROWDED FACILITY SAYING "YOU
NEED TO DO SOME THING ABOUT
THIS," ASK THE MAYOR OF
McALLEN, TEXAS, REPUBLICAN WIN
WHEN HILLARY CLINTON WON THAT
CITY BY 40%, AND 85% HISPANIC
POPULATION THERE AND THIS IDEA
THAT THEY KEEP STATING, WELL, ON
ONE HAND WE DON'T WANT YOU TO
COME BUT ON THE OTHER HAND, IS
THE PRESIDENT OF GUATEMALA SAID,
YOUR POLICY IS SAYING IF YOU LET
KIDS DAY AND FAMILIES AND
PARENTS DAY, COYOTES ARE GOING
TO BENEFIT FROM THAT.
THAT'S A SQUARE PEG IN A ROUND
HOLE, ON ONE HAND YOU CAN'T SAY
DON'T COME BUT YOUR POLICIES
ENABLE THAT.
THE FINAL THING IS, WHEN YOU ARE
DEALING WITH CRIMINAL MEXICAN
CARTELS MAKING $20 MILLION A DAY
BY TRAFFICKING WHICH THESE
POLITICIANS IN GUATEMALA ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS BEING
PROTESTED TODAY TO STOP FUNDING
CRIMINALITY, YOU NEED TOUGH
POLICIES TO STOP CARTELS FROM
PROFITING OFF OF THIS HUMAN
CRISIS AND APPARENTLY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS NO INTEREST
IN DOING THAT AND TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY AND SHE'S THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES COMING OUT OF
GUATEMALA SO MAY BE VISITING A
COUPLE TOWNS THAT ARE AFFECTED
BY THIS TO BE NICE.
>> Dana: IT DOES MAKE YOU
WONDER, REMEMBER WHEN ALL THE
DEMOCRATS WENT TO DO GRAND
GESTURES AT THE BORDER DURING
THE CAMPAIGN?
BUT WAS HAPPENING, I THINK
DURING CHILD SEPARATION POLICY
AND ALL THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO ASK YOU THIS,
BIDEN GIVES FOR THIS CHARGE 75
DAYS AGO, SHE'S WAITED, THREE
DAYS AGO SHE GOT THE ASSIGNMENT
TO TRY TO GET THE ELECTION BILL
PASSED FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND
JOE MANCHIN, THE SENATOR FROM
WEST VIRGINIA PUT A STAKE IN IT
OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> SHE IS THE GARBAGE CAN OF ALL
OF JOE BIDEN'S PRIORITIES.
TO KATIE'S POINT, I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT SHE'S
LOOKING FOR THE ROOT CAUSE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON GUATEMALA AND
NORTHERN TRIANGLE COMPANIES.
THERE IS A CRIME, THERE IS
CORRUPTION AND PEOPLE WANT TO
GET THE HECK OUT AND THE BORDER
IS OPEN.
CLOSE OUR BORDER AND HAVE PEOPLE
STAY IN THOSE COUNTRIES, THE
INNOVATORS, THE JOB CREATORS,
THE ENTREPRENEURS, IF THEY STAY
THERE THEY WILL FORCE THE
POLITICAL CHANGE AS NECESSARY
BUT WE THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
GIVE GUATEMALA IN THE NORTHERN
TRIBAL COUNTRIES, WE ARE GOING
TO KEEP THE BORDER OPEN FOR 20
YEARS ON LET PEOPLE COME UP AND
INTO THE COUNTRY?
I THINK WE AS AMERICANS HAVE A
RIGHT TO SAY WHO COMES IN AND
WHO DOESN'T.
IT'S NOT WHO WANTS TO TRACK
NORTH OVER 1500 MILES AND COME
IN.
WE WANT TO THINK THE CASE COULD
BE MADE THAT THE ACTUAL ROOT
CAUSES THE PROBLEM THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A SECURE BORDER.
>> Greg: I DO WANT THE PEOPLE
THAT TAKE THE RISK.
I'D WANT THEM TO DO IT LEGALLY.
BUT THEY ARE USUALLY --
>> Geraldo: THAT WALK
2,000 MILES.
>> Greg: WE WANT THE
INNOVATORS, WE WANT THE
CREATORS.
THEY MAKE IT OVER THE WALLS,
THEY FLY, THEY DID, THEY TAKE
BOATS.
THE PROS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
STOPPED.
THE --
>> Greg: WHAT HAPPENS TO
GUATEMALA IF THOSE PEOPLE STAY?
NOTHING